Throw away that antibacterial soap, no use
fighting it anymore.
Scientists have found bacteria are perfectly
happy living
in the clouds!
Clouds are pretty, and it’s fun to imagine
what the shapes are.
That one's a dinosaur holding a picnic basket!
That one's a box with… a lid.
And they're both filled to the brim with bacteria!
Bacteria are literally everywhere, on every
surface of everything all the time.
I mean, it's pretty obvious that bacteria
can live in the air down here, but they're
tiny after all and thus can be easily picked
up by the wind.
Full disclosure, I never even thought about
this, but bacteria have been found almost
25 miles up and all OVER in the clouds!
Scientists have found bacteria living above
rainforests and deserts, mountains and seas,
even inside hail and snow!
Before you freak out, that's not actually
a bad thing; they might help in cloud formation,
and can even live in lightning-prone storm
clouds to encourage rain or hail.
Researchers have found as many organisms in
parts of the sky as in an average river.
Clouds look pure and pretty, but on the microlevel
they're teeming with bacteria, algae, fungi
and other tiny plants and animals.
Microorganisms may see clouds as a giant transportation
system, growing and multiplying so the colony
can populate a new area, quote "piggybacking
on the hydrological cycle," said one scientist.
But, a new study in Environmental Science
and Technology has found bacteria are quite
happy to live in the upper atmosphere.
They're not just looking to populate new areas
alone!
They're okay with this crazy fly-by-the-seat-of-their-pants
life!
This study was specifically done on a species
of bacillus bacteria, in the Auvergne region
of France.
Bacteria have been collected from the sky
since the 1920s, so they probably flew up
and collected samples and brought them back
to Earth for testing.
But, somewhat unexpectedly, the researchers
found these cloud-borne microorganisms weren't
dormant and floating aimlessly, but were actively
consuming saccharides, or sugars, which are
also found in that white puffy stuff!
The sugars are blown there by the wind too;
originating from plants and microorganisms
on the ground.
The bacteria use those sugars to sustain themselves,
but more importantly as building blocks to
create polysaccharide armor which serves to
protect the little guys.
More research is needed, but it appears the
microbes have evolved to fight the stronger
UV rays which reach the clouds at high altitude;
not to mention the sub zero temperatures.
From there, they multiply, help form clouds,
and then rain, hail or snow back to Earth
again.
Amazing!
There's even bacteria on the Space Station
guys.
It's inescapable.
Are you freaking out?
Bacteria everywhere!!!
Or are you shrugging and living with the reality?